citizens of the reject Nation we are
here to do the Easter eggs reaction for
The Last of Us finale before we do our
live stream we're gonna do our live
stream soon guys this one's long dang
Paul this is longer than the episode
itself are you okay I'm excited to see
what you gotta say and of course Joy by
Andrew Gore Andrew Andrew
you're not excited to hear what I have
to say though are ya are you Greg no no
no okay it's okay no one else ramblings
hey leave a like check out our reaction
to the finale
let's just see what's going on
Paul you sexy Brit you pull
[Music]
okay so the last Last of Us season one
episode is you could have cut that we
could have saved ourselves 10 seconds
and this video wouldn't be this long
he said the last Last of Us season one
episode is now out and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down
episode nine all the Easter eggs hidden
details and also discussing the ending
first up though I want to thank everyone
for rocking with me the last nine weeks
and we're sort of like Joe lanelli a bit
because I doomed the entire human race
just to get a thumbs up from you hell
yeah do it the episode with a flashback
and this features a major game Cameo out
in the woods We join a pregnant woman
running and this is none other than
Ashley Johnson the voiced Ellie in the
game and here we catch her playing her
mother let's not forget she was also Mel
Gibson's daughter in what women want and
she was also Jean-Claude Van Damme's
niece in Lionheart which was directed by
Sheldon letish and he also directed The
Very uh follow-up film to that which was
so far several big actors from the game
have popped up including Tommy's voice
actor is Perry Troy Baker is James last
week and Marlene who shows up later on
in this scene Ali's mother is called
Anna and she was first mentioned in The
Last of Us comic American Dreams oh neat
featured alien Riley and in it we
learned a little bit about Anna and what
she did before the outbreak and I worked
as a nurse and we know she and her
lifelong friend Marlene survived
together when everything went down worse
and this Channel's views next week
[Laughter]
but here we see it flashed out with her
running to a farmhouse being chased by
an infected person we can see a big
symbol for the fireflies
and you can also catch what I'm guessing
is the Boston cuisine in the background
yes yes we know this was controlled by
Federer and though we don't learn why
Anna's out on her own like this it
likely has something to do with the
infected perhaps they were out on the
road and then they were ambushed and
Anna ended up fleeing which could have
led to this you know we did say in our
reaction that they look like a certain
kind of Farmhouse and we were referring
to I'm assuming we were both referring
to the Last of Us Part Two Farmhouse
that we or not at this boiler section
yet so we can't really go into however I
think it would be more poignant and
meaningful if for season two if that
Farmhouse does come into play for the
for Ellie they did make it this
Farmhouse that'd be yeah crazy I mean I
don't remember the location in the game
does it matter they change [__] they
could do it that's true because Kansas
City uh in this was Pittsburgh in the
game so yeah that's that's a good point
very true yes good points good points
all around from Greg
and Andrew's knowledge of Jean-Claude
Van Damme's Double Impact also just as
valuable here
two of them searching out in the wild I
think that this might have been the road
trip that they made in order to get the
qz and this could be them arriving for
the first time the thing about in
searching groups like this is that fedra
could scan for the infected but they had
no way of telling who was a rebel or a
firefly the sights still be allowed in
so potentially this is them just
traveling out of the city and then
everything kicked off along the way we
know that the area surrounding Boston's
full of infected too and that's my
theory ton on why she's out on her own
like this hopefully they address it on
the HBO post release podcast and if they
have then make sure you drop it in the
comments below yeah each of itself in a
room and then she bursts at a
switchblade which becomes one of Ali's
main weapons in the main game Sorry I
know this is a long video and I'm not
gonna hit pause too many times but I
gotta tell you during her reaction when
she took uh across the line I hit the
pause button
be honest when she took out her knife
were you thinking like she was like
gonna cut herself yeah I think we were
both on the same page about I was like
oh HBO what are you doing yeah no I mean
I figured she was being chased by
someone but like I was just so in the
Moment Like no don't do that don't do
that I thought she's gonna give herself
a C-section yeah okay I just want to
make sure we were on the same page can I
press the play button you you can press
the play better now go for it she
manages to kill the infected but
unfortunately during that she gets bed
as she gives birth the cordyceps
probably mutated during this moment and
this is why Ali ends up being immune in
episode one I saw an affection times and
due to the bite being on her leg she has
12 to 24 hours left with her child Anna
named her Ali
led by Marlene this group don't mind
shining flashlights as he infected don't
actually get alerted by them fun fact
the first time I played last of us I did
not realize you could shine a flashlight
on them and you'd be okay yeah no it it
took me I don't remember which try it
was where I realized I couldn't I know
with Runners and stalkers because they
can still see pretty well uh well I mean
stalkers half their face are gone but
yeah with clickers I don't remember if
it was the first time definitely the
second or third time I was like oh I can
shine a lighter on them but yeah I know
the first time I made sure like I cannot
have the light anywhere near the
clickers this was a big thing in the
game too and you did need to turn it off
when you were navigating around them and
Marlene goes upstairs to find Anna
holding a knife to her neck in case she
starts to turn she hasn't breastfed her
either in case she infects her and she
entrusts Marlene with her child also the
green jacket that she's wrapped up in is
what Ellie
oh [__]
and it also gives her the knife and this
is something that Marlene passed to her
in both the show and game they also
mentioned in the American dream comic
that it belonged to Anna Marlene
promises to look after Ellie that
totally flew over my head it flew over
both of the birds wow well she doesn't
wear the jacket in this episode right I
don't think it was this episode I don't
remember her wearing it in this episode
okay then maybe I might have noticed it
then if the show had done it oh God that
completely flew over my head I Blame You
what do I bring you here for if you
don't I'm pointing out these things I'm
a waste of time if you need to only
bring me on when it's Jean-Claude Van
Damme related in the future well get
ready because 2023 is about to take a
turn we got a lot of jcvd contact
she refuses to kill Anna initially but
realizing that it's a Judy she
eventually decides to duty very much the
entire point of Marlene's Arc in this
entry and we see how she attempts to put
the credit good above what she actually
wants to do though she swears to protect
Ali we see how at the end she approves
the operation that will kill her and
create a vaccine you the finale gray
area so the game does and in that when
you're moving through the hospital yes
you find some of her voice notes talking
about the situation they're pretty long
so I don't just want to spend ages
playing them but there are two recorders
that very much give her feelings at the
time the face is her coming back off the
reveal that Ellie needs to be killed for
the vaccine and she's angry that she
keeps getting tested over and over like
this the second is far more heartfelt
and it's actually addressed directly to
Anna yup she apologizes for breaking her
promise but says that she has to go
through with him yes this could save
everyone God damn that Anna and her
daughter will be reunited soon and also
states that she won't kill Joel because
he's the only person who may understand
how difficult his choice is like him the
pair both had to watch over Ellie but
this choice to spare Joel of course
damns them all now there's also some
really cool imagery in this moment and
Anna ends up giving birth to Ali beneath
an illustration of a tree trees have a
neural network underground like the
infected and Ally being born under this
carries the symbolism that a network
could spring from her that saves
Humanity this could also be seen as the
tree of life and it's some really nice
imagery to add into the scene now you
know I hate the next guy bloody hate him
but Ryan aryably Ryan was chatting to
him about the episode through the week
and he spot that Anna sings the song The
Sun always shines on TV by A-ha Take On
Me by the band was played at the mall
and Ellie also had one of their tapes up
in her room Take On Me is also a song
that appears in part two and Ellie sings
it at one point in the game damn I was
trying to pinpoint what that song was I
was like that's probably some important
Easter Egg song but I have no idea what
it is and it's interesting that they
would have this like symbolism moment
with Ellie being born under this tree
but then Joel is the fire to that tree
burns it all down right yes now I agree
with you but I really feel bad for for
Joel like having the the weight of this
whole decision like just feeling such
such portrayal but I always feel like in
the moment though that you know he's
protecting Ellie from like having to
feel responsible for any of this so
that's how I I view the moment but in
regards to your comment about him being
the fire I was gonna say
burning I don't know what I was going to
say but fire sounds good I mean yeah
Fire Burns yeah that's true that's true
fire fireworks for me too fire sounds
good you don't get to pause videos
anymore I've lost my privileges lost to
all privileges from here we jump to the
present and finally coming off the back
of the winter chapter in the game they
used every season to tell a sort of
self-contained story and we had things
like the tomian university sections in
the fall before Joe's recovery took
place over the winter nice nice place in
the spring and in that they've added a
couple of extra sections that we don't
get here we began with Jill and Ellie
out on Highway and the four more is the
one doing all the Talking for once this
is where we begin and we even have the
camper van that you're going through and
get supplies from similar to that Joel's
found stuff inside of it he tries to
shake Ellie out of the deep feelings
that she has you gotta tell me this Chef
Boyardee Moment Like This image right
here has to be like at the time we're
filming this it's not a meme yet but
this is this guy
look at that
it's definitely gonna be a meme people
gotta get creative and like replace
replace other things in there like a
baby Yoda I was gonna say grogu yeah
definitely or
type of
Hoy oh my goodness talking like a Buzz
Lightyear action figure yeah that's what
that's exactly what I was thinking Buzz
Lightyear I was thinking Woody actually
but
similar to that Joel's found stuff
inside of it he tries to shake Ali out
of the deep feelings that she has in the
game she was very much realizing that
she was at the end of the road and that
things here were almost over it is
important to bear in mind that Ali
actually wanted to go through with
everything even if it meant her death in
the end this is why Joe lies to her as
he knows she wanted her life to mean
something which is a line that she also
drops in part two I'll not spoil too
much of that but but little things that
helped to portray her thoughts I think
are important to bring her anyway on the
highway Ellie also knows it's an advert
for a plane which the show sort of
touched upon when they came across a
down one in episode three Ali said that
she'd had a dream where she was on one
and after going to the cockpit she
realized no one was flying it to me this
symbolized her realizing that no one
actually had a clue what they were doing
and that the adult she entrusted all
along were as directionless as she was
when you're a kid growing up you think
older people have everything together
but when you become one you realize
they've got no idea that Ali believe
that people like Moline and Joel would
lead him and deal with things but this
episode shows that they're driven by
Instinct and their own desires now
whereas we find Ellie sitting on the
back of a truck the game had a zoning
out to an engraving of a deer this was
clearly her remembering all the things
that happened for her to meet David and
it calls back at the one that she hunted
during the winter Ellie's also wearing a
red shirt at this point with Joel
dotting a grayish denim one which about
both characters were at this point in
the game and from here you move through
an abandoned quarantine camp that was
set up on the early days of the outbreak
before going into an underground tunnel
as little trickery though if you sneak
through and just stop it you can
actually avoid fighting all of them and
you don't know [__] that's not fun
though baby anyway from here the pair
made oh [__] around and they came across
a tunnel which had a burst pipe allowing
water to seep in when trying to navigate
over a bus this sprung free and Joel was
trapped in it as it was carried along
with the water with these cheap HBO
bastards for not doing this drowning and
with that passed out Joel had to swim
through he managed to make it through to
the surface which is where he tried to
resuscitate her it's at this point that
the fireflies showed up in the show they
pop up just out of the blue but we'll
talk about that more as we get up to
that bit in this story anyway back to
the episode and we see Jill messing
about with a backpack on the ground
similar to what you do in the games when
you're crapping and checking supplies
love it honestly I think they really
recapture the army of the chapter here
with the highway perfectly mirroring how
it is in the game now we also get a
mention of gel teaching Ali the guitar
in both the show and game
they had a guitar in that RV
you feel that breeze huh
I'll tell you on a day like this I just
sit on my porch
pick away my sex string it's all smashed
up but got me thinking maybe I should
find one I haven't played in forever
yeah once we're done with this whole
thing I'm gonna teach you how to play
guitar
I was thinking maybe I could teach you
I bet you'd be great at it
like that
what do you say huh
you want to learn how to play guitar I
love those scene comparisons there
because it really does capture the
difference between Pedro Pascal's
interpretation and Troy Baker's
interpretation like Troy Baker is kind
of speaking with this direct confidence
where Pedro Pascal's like hey I'm gonna
like there's a bit of a nervousness to
the way he's like you know yeah but I
like that because Pedro pasca I mean
look I'm saying I hate it I know you for
specifying I know you hate him that's
why I'm saying I like it I actually like
it for people who can't pick up on
Andrew sarcastic I I do like it because
look I know the highest form of flattery
is imitation but in this case I like it
when the actors make it their own
because I don't like what the actors
make at their own because I don't a
flattering you you're good that was good
I'm actually gonna give you props that
was good no but I I do like uh how Pedro
Pascal does different it is more you
know in terms of with his like his
interpretation of Joe like he does have
that that nervous Factor when it comes
to how he speaks to Ellie and also too
at this point too because if you
remember in the earlier episodes he just
viewed elia's car or belly excuse me he
just viewed belly as cargo and he like
had a more of a very demanding presence
towards her and if you will as what you
said earlier more of a confident
speaking tone towards her and so now now
that it's like his daughter he's a lot
more delicate in the way he talks to her
so yeah that's true
yeah that's true oh I'm flattered
we'll talk more on this super spoiler
section about how this plays into part
two but it's important to show how
Joel's regaining his Humanity he was
completely shut off from the world but
now he's becoming apparent once more and
showing interest in picking up a Guitar
again and showing Ellie his Hobbies you
also see a sign for Salt Lake City and
this was the location that appeared on
the map in the University you really see
the pair's relationship flourishing in
these moments with Ellie predicting beat
for beat about what they're going to do
to scout the area it's a great moment
between Mando and grogu and here we are
Logan James bus station terminal which I
always thought was a reference to
Wolverine as his full name's Logan James
Howlett if you're from Salt Lake though
and I'm absurd like a [__] then make
sure you call me a stupid idiot in the
comments and be like no it's a real
place and it's not named after Wolverine
anyway they spot a ladder and Jill
suggests boosting Ellie up in order to
grab it this is a mechanic that happens
in the game and you'd often show earlier
places so that she could drop one down
now this was something that you've gone
through time and time again but they
changed at the Dynamics by having Ellie
drop the ladder like what happens
yep
oh that's the PS5 version that's louder
whoa
that's actually it looks like a real
ladder they dropped that's that's a
pretty dangerous stud to put an actor in
yeah I mean I I agree with you obviously
everything is usually very well
choreographed but
if you're like playing it back it's just
like no yeah because it goes up and down
like no if that goes wrong it's like you
could break a finger get hit in the head
if that's truly really real and not just
a prop but it it does look real so yeah
I know some such a simple stunt like you
know you don't even think about like no
you really could get hurt on that sure
Tom Cruise would have loved to have done
that stunt yeah he's like I want you to
really drop it on my head
oh my God
we can see too he's kind of like gel
goes up like bracing his heads of steps
I'm not sure how long this giraffe's
neck is but this moment it's ripped
right out the game
and the music
[Music]
don't scare it
what are you doing it's all right I'm
gonna shoot it and use it for meat later
come on
what are you doing it's all right there
you go hurry up
[Music]
come on
can you hurry up come on
hey there
[Music]
good evening
so [__] cool I still can't tell if
it's a realtor I forgot either way it
looks good yeah
[__]
ing where's she going
come on come
on come on here come on let's go slow
down kiddo
and that was done to show that there was
still Beauty in the world even though
everything had come tumbling down though
Humanity might be on its last legs the
rest of the animals that live on the
planet had continued to thrive Noah's
Ark game carry a lot of symbolism with
them too and they're very much meant to
represent innocence Sarah yeah
there was one up in the kid's room in
episode six and they popped up
throughout both mediums at several
points in spirituality giraffes also a
symbol of Grace and overall they
represent patience in the game do they
really for the first time in a long
while and here you just looked over the
herd and had a moment to relax true
story one time was the Los Angeles Zoo
and there was a huge crowd gathered
around the giraffes and one giraffe was
trying desperately to do it with another
giraffe did you record it no I don't
know it didn't happen
sorry continue the story you are the
weirdest person to yes and with you know
that Andrew sorry continue I was trying
to tell you a true story where I
encourage giraffes to do it and suddenly
you just interrupt me with this thing
I'm sorry it was a real memory
continue the giraffes doing it I'm just
saying that's what happens when I see a
giraffe my mind goes to this memory I
have when I was I think 18 years old is
that the story yeah a version of it okay
well now I have something to look
forward to when I go to the zoo one day
yeah I do want to really quickly point
out uh whatever you're gonna point out
is not going to top my giraffe story I
just want everyone
giraffes doing it I know I thought that
um but
I gotta say I don't remember after a
reaction if I I mean I did mention and I
of course I praise Pedro Pascal's acting
but it's the little moments for me like
when he's just staring at Ellie or belly
excuse me and just admiring and like
just how much he reminds him of his
daughter and how she's become his
daughter just I love little moments of
that it's just I love where it's again
where the journey has started where they
began to where we've gotten to now it's
just it's such a bond and kinship and I
love it so much and that didn't top his
journey
that was an okay point but man sometimes
giraffe made is what I'm trying to get
out of here I'm gonna be watching for
that at the zoo next time and I'm gonna
send you that video yeah I'll be like
look what I saw don't worry from here
they go to a different part of the roof
and we get a scene for scene Recreation
of what happens in the game
[Music]
this is why this video is an hour and 45
minutes
[Music]
show didn't come up with any new scenes
so
is everything you were hoping for so
is it everything you hoped for
eign
called it that they switched places and
from the game
can't deny the view though
you can't deny that view
we don't have to do this
you know that right
I just I want you to know that
what's the other option
go back to Tommy's just
be done with this whole damn thing what
do you mean what else are we supposed to
do
today it means we forget about the whole
damn thing God damn it you know when
when last of us is running out of steam
and they need to do some type of weird
Multiverse movie they really gotta do
we're like Patriot Pascal and Bella
Ramsey going to some Universe where they
get to interact with the Ashley Johnson
and the uh Troy Baker version because as
much as it would not work now you know
there's a party that's like it might be
kind of cool let's just see that happen
I mean obviously not different than what
I'm about to say but obviously we got
Ashley Johnson and Troy Baker they were
so close to interacting in terms of with
Troy Baker uh but that would be that is
an idea we should start writing that
script soon I know we should get on that
and watch it get rejected right away
like whatever it is what is this crazy
you clearly don't understand the world
of the last place the supernatural
after all we've been through
we've been through
everything that I've done
everything I've done
I can't be for nothing
can't be for nothing
play this PS5 version so bad now Joel
offering Ali a chance to go to Tommy is
not really the thing that he wants for
her it's what he wants for him he knows
that once he drops her off at the
fireflies at the relationships no more
and he's gonna have to go back to
Jackson whilst she stays with them this
is his chance to become a father again
so he's giving her this option but he
ends up making the choice anyway at the
end when he goes full Rambo on everyone
yeah he also says sheep Ranch
and this is something that he brought up
around the campfire in episode six and
they go to the moon in the second game
want it for himself and we'll talk about
how this plays in a part two during the
spoiler section later on
which takes them to a makeshift qz Camp
his 2 is ripped right out of the
PlayStation classic though we do get two
very different emotional moments playing
out in both both Santa and Sarah and in
both the show and game we get Jill
explaining what exactly happened in the
series he says it wasn't fedra whereas
in the game it was anyway here's how the
explanations differ slightly this is
ephedra thing no
Army this place takes me back hostel
love it it was right after everything
went down
I ended up in a triage just like this
they put these places up all around
the first few days after the outbreak
and everywhere you look you just
sell families torn apart
whole damn world seem to have turned
upside down and blank they had me in one
just like this with Sarah
no she's gone already is that after you
lost Sarah
yes it will
can't imagine losing someone you love
like that
losing everything that you know
I'm sorry Joel anyway in the game at
this moment Ali ended up handing over a
photo of Sarah to Joel back with Tommy
he tried to do the same thing and we
learned that he'd return to Texas and
had stopped by their old house which is
where he found it Joe refused to look at
it or acknowledge it and it showed how
much of a closed book that he now was
Ali revealed that she'd stolen from
Tommy though and yeah she attempted to
give it back to him he ended up
accepting that he couldn't outrun his
past and it showed that he'd finally
moved on from feeling nothing but
constant grief and pain in the show
though he talks about almost ending his
own life and reveals a scar on his head
was self-inflicted now this skull was
something Ali asked about on the road
all the way back in episode three yup
Jewel said that someone shudded him and
missed and I wrongly assumed that this
scar was from when the soldier shot at
him in Sarah I just noticed that Pedro's
hair grows throughout the season I've
never noticed that did you notice that
his hair grew throughout the season uh
look at this
for some reason I never noticed that
yeah that's a great attention to detail
yeah for sure I mean the MCU has also
done a good job with doing not to get
into comparison but there's been times
where the MCU has really done a good job
with that too I remember with Captain
America Civil War after Bucky you know
hit Tony Stark in the face and then
Spider-Man homecoming came out because
that film took place like what like very
shortly right after and you could see in
the beginning of that that he still had
that so little attention to detail like
that really go a long way so I agree
with you no I I didn't even notice that
there are certain films though back in
the 80s where certain actors uh like did
you ever see the film The Secret of My
Success with Michael J fox no did you
see Cocktail with Tom Cruise no jeez
you're how am I supposed to make a point
when you haven't seen any movies what's
your job man I react to them anyways
really quick fun fun story obviously
this makes more sense in the sense in
the passage of time but there's this
funny 80s Trope with those two specific
films at least I don't know if there
were other 80s films where this happened
but in those two specific films I
assumed because they were filming other
films either the shots got picked up
later they'd have short hair when the
scene started and then later in the same
scene they'd have longer hair I'm like
what is happening here so that's
interesting that you caught that night
out because I usually catch those things
what am I here for Jean-Claude Van Damme
by the way make sure you get a t-shirt
you haven't had any G fuel right I had I
stole some before I started
Jill said that he wasn't scared and that
he was ready to do it and in the game
the character actually discussed people
that take their own lives they came
across someone and Ellie says that they
took the easy way out Raz Joel said that
it was never easy yeah he goes further
into it and says that he wasn't scared
and in fact he was ready he just hadn't
seen the point of living anymore when
Sarah died but he flinched when pulling
the trigger and he still doesn't know
why when we look at it he lived the next
20 years with nothing really to live for
and that was all until Ellie came along
the ending shows that he simply can't go
through that again and he doesn't care
who he has to kill to spare himself of
that pain he's also seen the worst in
humanity and the argument is definitely
there whether it's worth sparing one
good person for us like the last of us
if you imagine nihilists concern that
Humanity deserve what happened to them
and Jill very much represents the Riley
mind state of wanting to spend whatever
time he has left with the person he
cares about ali then says Time Heals all
wounds but he says it wasn't that that
did it Ellie has saved him he does what
he sees is saving her and thus saving
himself it's going it's kind of picky
poison on what version you prefer
they're both great and you know I'm a
die-hard fan of the latter but I
actually think that it worked better in
the show yes enlightened by some puns
it's a necessary Point people are making
a pop Clips jokes like there's no
tomorrow people are making apocalypse
jokes like there's no tomorrow
too soon
a moon rock Earthly Rock
oh I love this one moon rocks tastes
better than Earth rots why because it's
meteor
meteor that's terrible that was actually
good one of the green grapes say to the
purple grape
breathe you idiot
so stupid
what did the green grape say to the
purple grape
you idiot what about the fun is spoiled
by a firefly flashbang might not be a
flashbang I'm not a weapons expert and
every time I get it wrong people kick
off so yeah if it's not call me an idiot
in the comments below and make sure you
get those comments up anyways
reminiscent of Sarah waking up in
episode one we cut to some blinds
flapping back and forth before we find
Joel in a hospital bed windows are very
important the last of us and one was
used on the menu screen with a similar
setup for this being used at the end of
episode three Joel initially believes
that he sees blood but this then forms
into a firefly shape or shadowing what's
to come now from here we get a scene
[Music]
lovely fireflies
welcome to the fireflies
sorry about that
they didn't know who you were yeah
you're pretty hard
and Ellie she's all right they brought
her back
where's Zoe she wasn't her
not even a scratch he's mostly worried
about you
you came all this way
how'd you do it I have five men whose
only job was to protect me I still
almost got killed
do it
it was her
she fought like hell to get here
what is over
she felt like hell to get here she would
have been dead on day one
maybe it was meant to be
I lost most of my crew cross in the
country
I pretty much lost everything
I lost half our crew crossing the
country
but I owe you
we all know he understood me to her you
don't have to worry about her anymore
we'll take care I worry
let me see her please
I can't
she's being prepped for surgery
you can't
what surgery
the hell you mean surgery the doctors
tell me the cordyceps the growth inside
her has somehow mutated
our doctor
he thinks that the cordyceps in Ellie
has grown with her since birth
it's why she's immune
once they remove it they'll be able to
reverse engineer a vaccine it makes
normal cordyceps sync the cheese
cordyceps it's why she's immune
scene
but it grows all over the brain
cordyceps grows inside the brain
it does
find someone else there is no one else
it's so interesting watching
specifically Pearl Dandridge yeah like
doing this because he does do like a
slightly different shade of her
performance here you could feel more in
the live-action one like she's probably
had a really tough conversation and
she's had to shut herself off from
caring so she has to be a little bit
more like cold about it all yeah we're
here in the game you get more hints that
this is hard hard for her you know it's
just fascinating to see like the same
actor do both the game and the live
action and still bring something
different to the live action when the
dialogue is very close to being the same
thing yeah no I was actually I was
thinking that while we were reacting to
it and just now I'm like it's got to be
such an interesting dilemma as an
actress because you don't usually play
the same role in in the same medium like
this unless you're James Earl Jones
unless you're drinking yeah that's true
good point touche but no that no that's
but that's an interesting Dilemma to
have to be in like okay I mean I gotta
say a lot of the same lines of dialogue
but I don't want to play this the exact
same way because I don't want to come
off as imitating myself so
did you want to say something else
I wanted to touch your nose okay
so you were gonna show me
find someone else there is no one else
take me to her you take me to her right
now
stop I can't
I get it please you don't understand
you do
but whatever it is you think you're
going through right now is nothing to
what I have been through I was doing she
was born nor Hollow at the live-action
I promised her mother I would look after
her then why why are you letting this
happen because this isn't about me
I'm the only one who understands
there is no other choice here
I have no other choice
[Music]
yeah you keep telling yourself that
[__]
March them out of here
he tries anything shoot him
walking out to the highway leaving there
with his pack if he tries anything
shoot him we also add in some extra
lines of dialogue explaining how and why
Ellie is immune as we learn in episode 2
the cordyceps work almost like a hive
mind with that being vast wires of them
underground this very much extends to
how they work with the immunity too and
they see her cordyceps as normal so they
don't attack a multiply these chemical
Messengers being replicated could end up
being a cure and this Moline sees elia's
array of light now there are certain
things that come with this and if you're
ever getting to talking about whether a
Joel was right or wrong you'll run into
people who say the vaccine wouldn't have
worked anyway and that there was a
chance it could fail there's definitely
that possibility too
it does make it way clearer either way
the Firefly is having this cure could
have completely shifted the Power
Balance on the planet and they would
very much become the rulers of Earth
deciding who got immunity and who did we
were talking about they're as cruel as
the rest of the groups we've encountered
and as we know they completely hate
Federer well you obviously give the
vaccine to the people who can afford it
duh Whoever has the most rations
we want to get back on track
capitalism that's what you do in an
apocalypse Firefly Pharmaceuticals
there's got to be a way to profit off of
the vaccine
so you know I think the pharmaceutical
industry getting that back on the rise
would be our first order of business
definitely I'm you know Joel or Pedro
Pascal's character of Joel he ruined
that for all of us because I want to see
that in Last of Us I don't care about
Ellie I want I just want to see the
fireflies with their vaccine starting a
pharmaceutical company and exploiting
capitalism in that way that that's
really what I want to see fly Aid is
what they would call it open 24 hours
we're also complete heads and who knows
whether they'd even be able to replicate
at scale I think whenever I've played
through this section on the game as well
I've always thought that the big thing
Marlene didn't do that she should have
is let Joel and Ellie say their goodbyes
I agree as soon as she gone to the
hospital she was pretty much scan rushed
to surgery and there wasn't that chance
where Joel could make his peace with
what was happening they wanted the Cure
as soon as possible and whether that's
to gain power or save people I'll leave
that up to you to decide now Marlene
says that she was there when she was
born but she's very much sacrificing her
and her feelings to do what she sees as
being best for the planet what I love
about the ending is that there's no
right or wrong answer and you can fully
see Joel as being the bad guy had people
not played as him or watched him in the
show then I think that would definitely
be the case too on paper this is a man
who stormed a hospital and used it as a
shooting gallery so that he could kidnap
a girl and lie to her about what
happened these aren't the Hallmarks of a
hero but I can also see why people don't
like Marley neither had Joe let them do
it they could have held the world to
Ransom and though I don't think stopping
them from doing that was his intention
there are questions to be asked now in
addition for the show Molly instructor
Gods to give him Ali's switchblade and
this carries a lot of significance Anna
gave it to Marlene at the beginning and
I very much view this as her trying to
get rid of the girl she's gonna carry
every time she looks at it this item
brought with it a promise that Marlene's
gone back on and her giving it to Joel
very much reminds him of what he's
fighting for she did try her best to be
fair and she even enrolled Ellie and
Federer so that she'd be far away from
the fireflies still though her immunity
brought them together Molly now sees Ali
as being a hope but he Humanity the
blade is of course so he can survive but
Joel's gonna to remember her every time
he looks at it as well we're getting
added shot also wasn't in the source
materials which are rolling down
Marlene's face to show how difficult
this was yeah now it is also possible
that she suspected Ellie was immune due
to the birth and this is why she wasn't
immediately shot when she revealed she
was infected we don't really find out
how Ellie ended up with the fireflies
but it's possible that she went directly
to Marlene after hearing about her from
Riley and the game Joel was taken out by
one God in the scene however here he's a
scored by two but he still manages to
get the upper hand he stops at a sign
before he hits the stairwell and this is
so he can see what floor she's on I love
how in this shot it's just like so
convenient that okay like the production
design was like make everything else
kind of like dirty and washed out but
really clean up the number four floors
on so many audience can read it right
away it's film and TV of course there's
no I'm not mad at it
I'm not my brother whose Channel you go
on who would be really vehemently it
raged over a filmmaking decision I
respect what they did here
pretty clean while the rest is very yeah
we only need to worry about this one
floor here yeah and then makes us move
by killing them both such a good moment
and he interrogates the god like what we
get here
I got time for this
[__] you doing keep walking the [__] are
you doing keep walking
I said keep walking
where's the operating
where is she
I ain't got time for this
where top floor the far end
now he takes his knife back along with
his backpack and switches into cold
Terminator mode
[Music]
there's no line he won't cross no one he
won't kill and he mercilessly moves
through the hall sparing of people even
if they surrender this bit was so
intense in the game too when you pretty
much work your way through the hospital
killing everyone that you came across I
really think it's a beautiful Montage
even if it's horrific I got goosebumps
seeing this player
reaction yeah you pervert you can catch
the paintings that they had in the wall
which are perfectly recaptured in the
show we also have rooms after the side
and this is where you'd find the
recorders and so on like in the game
Joel steps through the main door and he
then sees Ali about to be operated on I
won't let you take her
I won't let you take her now this
character becomes very important later
on and we do get some focus on him as
Joe leaves
is alive hey you're a better man than me
Joel cause I was smashing them like the
like button
now he ends up getting to the elevator
wow he didn't point out
who the nurse was Abby Laura Bailey here
foreign
I told you like in our reaction I I know
for a fact that we're gonna have
comments I can't believe you guys didn't
mention it was Laura bed it's like okay
clearly you didn't get to that part of
our video you done after Paul yeah no
but luckily for us you literally paused
it right as we begin our discussion
after I I had done my bit and then you
got into your Spiel I noticed a name I
was like
oh okay so I was right happy wheels he
might point it on the spoiler section
maybe we shouldn't get ahead of our show
yeah sorry Paul if you did point that
yeah sorry you know advance in case yeah
but if not condemnation but so yeah guys
before Common Police coming to our video
here what happened was is that Paul is a
friend of mine and because he's seen
that we've been reacting to his videos
he gifted us with letting us get early
access to his video ahead of time then
you know after if we were done filming I
was like I I should probably let Paul
know that about this Easter egg not
being in the video If you go to his
channel it's in there now uh not trying
to get credit or something like that I'm
just telling you why in this particular
reaction it's not in here and really the
credit goes to Andrew if we're noticing
it too but and he didn't mention though
the the parallels of the Gustavo
santalaya music uh you remember the the
music that we love when he's carrying
Ellie out in the game versus when he
goes full-on Terminator mode so he did
forget to do that unless he's gonna yeah
Paul your work is wasted now waste of
time I say and in the game he's chased
by soldiers but I think it makes more
sense to have him just make his Escape
yeah I agree I agree it's very much done
in the game to keep up the tension Raz
here he's clearly internally struggling
with what's going on now the ending of
The Last of Us is semi had stuck with me
since I first played the game back in
2013 killing doctors like this is
clearly crossing the line but you could
see things from Joel's point of view as
he'd been playing as him for the last 10
hours or so as Joe leaves he carries
Ellie out and this is symbolic for a
number of reasons it's exactly the same
as how he carried Sarah at the start of
the series and Ellie very much
represents the daughter that he lost he
also gets put in a similar situation to
how he was with Sarah at the beginning
right as we had a soldier standing with
a gun drawn ready to shoot them we see
that Marlena stands between him and the
life that he should have Marlene tries
to talk him out of it and she says that
if Ellie doesn't die for something like
this then she'll know that die for
nothing because of the way the world is
the in fact it could Tarot part writers
could kill her and we've seen throughout
the season how many threats lie around
Each corner she always says especially
infected inside but that's very much the
case with Jill as well what about
Marlene correctly says that they both
know what Ellie would do which is
confirmed later on in the story by the
character herself in the game we get the
resolution of the scene playing
alongside gel and Ali driving out of the
area let's play these scenes together so
you can see how they compare can't keep
her safe forever
you can't save her
even if you get her out of here then
what how long till she's torn apart by
infected or murdered by Raiders
how long before she's Torn to Pieces by
a pack of Clickers
that is that she hasn't been raped and
murdered first
maybe geez but it isn't for you to
decide for you I mean for you to decide
it's
it's what
you know it so what would she decide
what's right
look
you can still
do the right thing here
even after what you've done
still find a way
she won't feel anything
[Music]
I love that transition
perfect
good fake out
[Music]
what the hell am I wearing let's take it
easy drugs are still wearing off all
right you're with me
take it slow the drugs are still wearing
off what happened
[Music]
fireflies
turns out there's a whole lot more like
you
people that are immune so
people that are immune it's dozens
actually
I'm a damn bit of good neither
dozens of them the doctors they couldn't
make any of it work
they've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure
I'm taking that home
leaders attacked the hospital I barely
got you out of there
turned around there too
[Music]
wait
a minute
let me go
Brian
you just come after her
now an important addition here is a line
about Raiders attacking the hospital I
always wondered why Ali didn't question
why they got out of there so quickly
without saying goodbye but this lot
helps to add why they had to leave
straight away it also means that if they
go back there they can see the bodies
and this lines up with the idea that
they were attacked by an unknown group
yes I don't know if they wanted money or
they wanted something more sexual but
it's a lucky thing I had my pieces
pieces my gun oh anyway I started
blasting back wow I don't see so good so
I missed then they ran away anyway you
guys all think I'm a hero and I'll
accept that responsibility
you see Joe mercilessly shooting Marlene
and her wound is repeat of the last time
with her getting hit in the side the
shows just how far Joe is willing to go
and she's meant to be a sympathetic
figure in this moment you need to have a
bulletproof vest Joel isn't willing to
take any chances and he kills her
because there's a chance you'll still
come Valley again Marlene has very much
given up her Humanity in deciding to
sacrifice Ellie for the vaccine Raz gel
has found his once more through
regaining a daughter now the car breaks
down by the side of the road and we get
a similar thing to what happens in the
game Ellie looks at her by Mark and she
very much views this as the thing that
was driving her but now it no longer
really serves a purpose Beyond
protecting her from getting infected
Joel says they have a five hour hike
ahead of them which they joke about
managing and this is a call back to
episode 3. they also discussed having a
five hour hike then too and like the
game at this point he starts to talk
about Sarah and how the pair would have
been friends I don't think I ever told
you but uh
Sarah and I used to take hikes like this
well Sarah and I used to hike like this
all the time
I think uh
I think the two of you would have been
would have been good friends I think you
really would have loved it
anyway I bet you would have liked her
back
now we can see conflict with an alley
and she's clearly weighing up whether to
question Joel as he spouts off stories
about his daughter just like the game
they arrive overlooking Jackson but here
we see it carries the updated design
from part two with the giant wall
surrounding it the pal look over it and
we get Ali asking the question in a
scene that's pulled right out of the
game not much further now
it's a little bit further now
hey wait
hey wait back in Boston Kansas City you
asked me about the first time I killed
someone back in Boston oh see there you
go
back when I Was Bitten
I wasn't alone and I got bit in the mall
I wasn't on my own my best friend was
there my best friend was there
and she got bit too
if we didn't know what to do and she
says
you can just wait it out feel poetic and
just lose our minds together we didn't
know what to do
so
she says
let's just wait it out
I can't wait to play this game again
and then she did
and I had to
I'm still waiting for my turn Ellie her
name was Riley and she was the first to
die
her name was Riley
she was the first to die
and then it was Tess
Sam
and Sam
and then it was chess and then Sam
that's not on you I know it none of that
is on you
you don't understand I struggled
for a long time with surviving but if
you just keep going you find something
new to fight for
maybe that's not what you heard of me
and you
no matter what
you keep finding something to fight for
now I know that's not what you want to
hear right now swear to me
is true
from Superman right yeah you said about
the fireflies is true
I swear
love the music they're swear
[Music]
O'Reilly and the line about losing their
minds together is a reference to this
they could just be a poetic and [__] and
loser
it'll assist immense the Survivor skill
at Ellie feels which is reoccurring here
once more Ellie is once more living
whilst people are dying that she could
have helped and she Bears the burden of
it he's very much wanting to know that
there isn't another side to it and that
all the deaths meant something Riley
Tess Henry and Samuel died so that she
could get to the hospital the lives were
very much wasted in her eyes because of
Joel's actions he swears that everything
he said was the truth and Ellie pauses
and then says okay this is a line that's
always stuck with me as she's not really
saying whether she believes it or not
she's just saying okay I will accept
that version of events
or asking further questions she's happy
to live in this reality where her father
figure isn't a monster in her mind she's
going along with it that he tried his
best to get her to the fireflies but
right is attacked and it didn't work out
now did he do the right thing well
that's definitely Up For Debate but deep
down he knows that it's not what Ali
wanted which is cemented by the fact
that he has to lie to her had it been
what Ali was really after then he
wouldn't have hit the truth and he
doesn't want to seem like a selfish
monster in his new Daughter's Eyes he
wants to be the father figure in her
life that she's been craving all along
and he knows that telling the truth will
completely shatter this illusion and
this works both ways as well with Ellie
not so much believing a lie but she
accepts it since playing the first game
I've always referred to it as being the
Godfather of gaming and that's mainly
down to how the ending plays out in that
seminal film Michael's girlfriend K
arrives at his home and his sister bear
sin and accuses him good Paul yeah
Michael denies all this and this is
because he's attempting to retain the
idea in case mind that he's a good man
who isn't like the rest of them good God
we end with the Mobsters coming and
clearly treating Michael like a Mappy
head the door is then shut on her as she
realizes the truth deep down that's very
much the case with Ellie too and she's
now going on in Jackson with Joel
believing that he he's not someone who's
just doomed Humanity really quick that
was a very good callback in regards to
Godfather but we got to give credit to
me and not Paul that he didn't do the
blade callback reference that I made at
the beginning of the episode like where
you had Paul on that just saying
can you hear me oh there we go now you
can hear me
repeat and say that again that was a
very good call back on Godfather right
there at which I give full credit to
Paul but I'm going to give credit to
myself
I keep laughing I'm gonna give credit
I'm gonna give you this whole time yeah
I'm gonna give credit to myself on what
happened at the beginning and our
reaction we talked about when uh Ellie's
Mother Anna got played by uh of course
Ashley Johnson got bit it reminded me so
much of Blade the parallels there so I
don't see you coming up with that yeah
so where you at you know the third time
address you wanna do a fourth time no
I'm good you sure I want to give credit
to myself here for coming up with the
blade thing belly just saying belly
belly HBO Max where you at by the way in
that PS5 version could you tell the
certain doctor character that we won't
talk about until the spoiler section
they have updated it to make it look
more like as opposed to when you play it
on PS4 PS3 they Tamara morrisoned him
yeah
yeah yeah I know what I mean yes yes
totally actually yes now you can totally
see things from Joel's side too and I
think that had anyone else been given
Ellie then we likely would have had a
different ending Marlene and the rest of
the fireflies were happy to sacrifice
her but the fact that Joe was someone
who never got over his daughter makes
him the worst person to be escorting her
he sees the similarities and eventually
comes to believe that Ali is very much
his daughter which is cemented by
certain things that he does he calls her
baby girl at the end of episode 8 and
this is a nickname that he also used
with Sarah Joel also glances at his
watch at several points and these all
happen in moments in which he sees
similarities in them are they just
playing soccer with Sam causes him to do
it and it slays throughout lots of
aspects of the show it did remove the
moment from the scene at the end in
which he does it too but it's an
important thing to bear in mind as it
was there originally Joel needs to find
a reason to live and it's also cemented
by the fact that you find something to
survive for when he lost Sarah he wanted
to give up and attempted to end his own
life however he must have had help deep
down that things would work out which is
why he flinched he's now found the thing
to make him whole again and he'll do
whatever he can to keep Ali at his side
even if it Dooms The Last of Us it's a
chilling way to close out the season and
I'm so glad that they kept the scenes
this year thank God it's perfect the
first time I saw it and I still think
that it's perfect now now that closes
out the episode and for the next part of
the video we're going to be talking
about the consequences of this and what
it leads to in season two but part two
but it's probably gonna be season two so
there are Major Spoilers here and with
the first season following the game so
closely I can't imagine that season 2
will follow the second game pretty
closely as well so if you don't want to
know what happens then I highly
recommend you turn off now oh yeah let's
go I mean heavy heavy spoilers like
people will be mad you're gonna bring
your eyes in the super spoiler section
you can't get mad you promised you
wouldn't
right so the first thing that we need to
talk about is the fact that Joel dies
early on in the second game he's killed
by Abby who we discover was the door of
the doctor that Joel kills in order to
take Ellie we learned that for years
Abby trained her body to beat Perfection
this happens as well and along with a
group of people she heads out from
Seattle to Jackson Joel saves her from a
whole of the infected but she still ends
up killing him which is what sets Ellie
off on a quest to avenge him that's
pretty much the plot of the second game
without getting too much into spoilers
but yeah Pedro Pascal might not be a
long long in the second season anyway I
do wonder if in the second season We'll
add more flashbacks with Joel and uh if
Pedro Pascal was aware of this before he
signed oh God there's no doubt in my
mind he was aware I mean have you heard
the stories of him signing on to the
show no actually he's like how he was in
London and he got the call and he was
asked he was told he could read the
scripts and he was like fighting to get
the job like he had never played the
game or even I'm not even sure he's
heard it but he heard of the game before
oh like he casually mentioned to like I
think his nephew was and said he's gonna
be like trying to get this role in this
thing called The Last of Us his nephews
were like you've got to get this room so
like was he fully away I'm sure he found
out like yeah but like before he said
yes was he did he know Joel was gonna
die you just to me the answer is yes
from the story you just described
because if his nephews were that into it
once he accepted the wrong sure his
nephews at the minimum had that
conversation if Neil druckman and the
producers and all that didn't I find it
fascinating that Pedro Pascal has to
fight for her role though he's such a
freaking amazing act I get it this is
probably a very sought out role uh for
actors I just feel like Pedro Pascal at
this point he's so damn proven like I
mean it was down like they they sought
him out but it's like they usually seek
out a few people right right just like
screened we got to screen test you with
the act with you and a couple other guys
did they say who the other actors were
that were possibly testing out or just
only painting a Finn wolf hard and you
know Finn wolfhard no I don't oh wait is
that fantastic if you look up film
wolfhard I think Finn wolfhard would
have been a perfect pick are you making
a joke I think Finn wolfhard would have
outdone Pedro Pascal surprised you I
don't know if in a little farm
and Noah schnapped too oh God do you
know who that is no I'm but I'm thinking
these are punny names that you're making
funny names they're real the real actors
really no schnapp you don't know no snap
no I don't oh my God yeah he would have
been perfect Joe Kiri do you know what
that is no but these don't sound like
Gary would have been perfect these don't
sound like real people they sound like
names that you're making fun of me of
they're not they're real people you
should look them up Kayla McLaughlin
nope never heard of this oh oh yeah they
had like at least five other people who
I think would have been maybe better
than Pedro Pasco
okay
it sounds good do me a favor never look
them up yeah I'm not I wasn't going to
the next thing I want to talk about is
the line about the guitar and the RV
party opens on Joe hauling it and this
is a very important item that reoccurs
throughout we know that in between this
pod and part two that Ali learns to play
it and she picks it up and strums away
at several points in the game the ending
of it very waste of time grounded and
after failing to kill Abby and being let
go Ellie ends up living on a ranch with
her girlfriend Dina and also her son
this is a sheep farm like what Joel said
he wanted in the season and with his
added context it's very much Ali living
Joel's dream it's very much Ellie living
Joel's dream we also get references to
the moon coming with a flashback showing
Joel taking Ali to a museum for her
birthday they end up sitting inside a
shuttle and board and with a helmet and
headphones on Ellie imagines going to
liftoff now back to the guitar and after
Ellie experiences constant pts
flashbacks she ends up leaving to hunt
Abby down after Tommy tells her
Santa Barbara completely disheveled
after being captured by a group of
slavers known as the Rattlers she ends
up saving her but as she goes to sail
off Ellie once more gets a PTSD
flashback and she forces Abby to fight
her during this fight Abby bites off her
fingers and though Ellie gets the upper
hand she decides to let her go this is
because she remembers Joel and she
learns that she could forgive him and
thus forgives Abby too people kick off
about it it's my favorite part about
that is leading up to that fight with
Abby Ellie Slaughters like a gazillion
people it's an apartment the Rattlers
yeah it's just annihilates so many
people yeah and then when she finally
gets to Abby she's like
no
Joe would want me to get rich
this is now when it's time it's
convenient timing to now forgive but I
think that's why in the show there's not
just like endless body counts because
[__] like that will pop up and there's
also different contexts they have uh Lev
with Abby which is a reflection of Joel
and Ellie so yeah no definitely
someone's got to take care of this left
kid because you know that uh Ellie's not
gonna do it Ellie returns home to find
that Dina has left that she's left her
some of her belongings including Joel's
guitar Ali starts to strum this and she
attempts to play Future Days by Pearl
Jam which is the song that Joe played to
her at the start of the game because of
her missing fingers she's unable to do
this and she very much lost everything
including a piece of Joel in this quest
for Revenge
[Music]
are we getting open window some of the
how the scene with Sarah started in
season one I also imagine that the
hospital scene will return but we'll get
this from A New Perspective like what we
didn't again yes absolutely Russian to
find her father dead in the wake of
Joel's Rampage and I was actually
surprised that they didn't at least send
to her in the final episode I still
think season two will play out like how
it did in the game but maybe they just
didn't have her cast yet or maybe he
just didn't want to have the
conversation around the finale but see
that's the thing like that takes me back
to the episode where we got in Jackson
with Dina yeah I know I'm sorry I
pressed this Facebook but it takes me
back to the it takes me back to the
episode with Dina like do you think two
questions one do you think
and you're probably going to answer
sarcastic so I'm not going to know if
you're being honest or not it's been
wolfhard yeah damn you I can't believe I
fell for that do you think the actors
that they had D I know that wasn't like
she had no speaking lines I was
literally a two second Cameo but do you
think that actress is actually going to
play Dina and also for Dr Jerry Anderson
he was wearing a face mask so it's like
we I mean I know they put in the cast
they put his name in there because
obviously there was an actor there but
if you think that actor's gonna be
playing Jerry or do you think they cup
purposely covered his face which I know
they did in the game as well but hey we
have to have an actor here for this
specific scene but we haven't cast the
actor yet so let's just put since it's
going to be a mask covering his face
like we can get away with that one but
we don't want to do this with Abby
because this is a very integral role
that we need like what do you what are
you thinking uh sarcastic first off I
think is a smart move not to show any of
Abby because I think that would have
overshadowed the entire conversation
online and especially that's true really
hard to protect spoilers everyone would
have been like that's Abby who's
yeah and uh as far as the one with the
surgeon all right I doubt that he's
gonna be the actor Finn wolfhard is she
give him wolfhard play Abby is what I'm
saying
and also don't forget to purchase
t-shirts yeah shopster edition.org
maybe they just didn't want to have the
conversation around the finale being a
very very controversial one because that
is a very controversial figure there's a
face model for her still gets sent hate
mail and stuff in yeah people are going
to be very mad I think anyway that's all
the spoilery Easter eggs in the entry
now with the last of us first season
wrapping up I thought I'd give myself
the nurse maybe I ask them whether I
think the gamer shows then I have to go
with the former I think the game is
probably gonna remain my favorite of all
time for most of my life another would
be pretty difficult for the series to
Top This how about the series start off
really strong and after those first
three episodes it crossed my mind a
number of times that I actually thought
that this was better than the game the
characterization changes cast action
scenes in drama worked really well
leading it to being such a strong start
however I do feel as we got under the
latter parts of the Season that the
formula became very clear and every
episode sort of slaughtered into us
being a new character having an
adventure with them and then watching
them die having across the board and I
think that the latter episode sort of
lost their variety though I enjoyed
episode six and seven I think putting
them back to back made it feel like this
story was dragging a lot and if you
compare things to how those moments are
handled in the game there's a lot more
variety it broke things up with the
infected and Raiders attacking Raz
outside of the ones that popped about
the end of each episode it didn't really
have those Dynamics there's so many
Stellar infected scenes as well that
didn't make the cut in the series which
I think is a shame because the clicker
moments in episode 2 are handled so well
yeah I wanted to see this translated
things like the hotel basement the
tripwire trap as they arrive at bills
the sewer escape and pretty much every
section of the game in every episode the
thing they tend to cut was the infected
moments and I think that's probably
going to be a turn off for General
audiences who are sold on this being a
big post-apocalypse show I think what's
missing when people say like the action
or clickers is that the last of us at
the end of the day is a survival horror
drama yes you know yeah and it really
seemed to dial back the horror side of
things the survival horror side of
things was something that I really felt
is a staple to to the game because when
they actually did do those things they
executed like this is genuinely like
scary and and we kept saying like even
in a rears like oh my God they've done
they've brought the infected to life and
like I genuinely feel scared for these
characters been it's also like we're not
in control right now like we are in the
video game so it's like obviously if you
know the game you know what's going to
happen in terms of that but still you
genuinely feel scared for these
characters especially at the point where
it's live action you're not in control
anymore but I agree I wish just just a
little bit more but again they got the
most important stuff down Joel and Ellie
they got the characters down they got
the psychological aspects now they got a
lot of the you it's only bothers me when
I'm remind did of it like when I see a
video like this and I'm like damn those
sewer scenes were freaking intense
weren't they like yeah then I'm like
would have been nice to have that it's
like that's what I'm most bothered
because when I'm seeing something that
reminds me of it well yeah I agree with
you again I was saddened that that one
but a notice unlike Greg I didn't
complain that that scene was was cut out
and I know I was accused of the business
way to throw me under the bus I I mean
you also you made me look like an idiot
like 10 minutes ago with the whole Finn
wolfhard and all that other stuff so but
anyways point I'm making is how did I
make you look like an idiot I made
myself look like an idiot that's right
now I've especially made you look
anyways point I'm making is I literally
had no complaints for the most part
about them cutting out certain action
sequences and I thought I made a logical
explanation of why I was a little upset
that one specific one because I thought
it was character-driven action and it
was also storytelling driven action and
also it like it was the build up of the
trust is are you getting your tricep
workout yeah I think it was the the
building of trust between Ellie and
David and all that like even for people
who had never played the game that's why
for that and again I didn't need 20 or
30 minutes of clickers like David and
Nelly like fighting off clicker even if
it would have been like
even if it would have been like fire
even if it would have been like five or
six minutes even like again they didn't
you could even have taken out the bloat
or after all okay I just wanted to see a
few minutes of that again that was the
only sequence that truly bothered me
personally for the whole season uh of
taking out an action sequence because
all the other ones would I have liked to
have seen them in absolutely but they
weren't necessary to what was happening
on the show and from that again visually
would have loved to have seen it but it
didn't hurt the storyline got that out
of my system by the camera is not
rolling oh my God I gotta start working
out with water bottles damn I'm weak in
comparison comparison
are generally I gotta do I gotta start
doing I gotta start doing 21s yeah baby
I do 21 year olds oh
uh yeah
21. oh okay my bad that's foreign
there's probably people who've just seen
the series I think you know the game
might it's probably going to be boring
but trust me if you pick up and play
that you'll understand how much was
missing they did clearly lean more in
towards the drama side of things and
whether that's for Budget reasons or not
it did pale in comparison to me I just
felt like some of the things I think of
first when thinking of the game were
exercised and this is all in favor so
that we didn't get listen mode all
season yeah
so it really went out on a high and I
think in the finale especially was
really well done I was worried when I
saw the run time that it wouldn't
deliver I agree I did and watching Joel
walk through the hospital like that
really struck a chord with me I knew it
was the wrong thing to do but I was so
glad that he was also doing it yeah The
Last of Us is a complex show and though
it did filter at some points I think
this overall was a brilliant adaptation
for what's a truly stellar game now if
I'm scoring it then the game for me is a
10 out of 10 with the show coming in at
about an eight some brilliant moments in
this yeah to me it said a high bar early
on dropped off a bit and then picked up
at the end
so yeah I felt slightly short of what I
was expecting and if you haven't played
the game then I'm sure you enjoyed it
way more than I did I did still enjoy it
don't kick off don't stop kicking off
you gave it a name Paul you hate it so
good it's difficult to not be like well
I wish they did this you know what I'm
saying yeah and if you love the game I'm
sure you'll have sort of similar
feelings anyway season two next and uh
that's gonna be a very interesting oh my
God I can't wait
definitely but yeah huge thank you for
rocking with me for the last nine weeks
I know there's been lots of great
breakdowns out there doing really good
things um and what I've tried to do with
this to kind of differentiate them is
make this the obsessive Gamers breakdown
where we go as in-depth as possible
point out all the most minuscule stupid
things and yeah people who are obsessed
over this game I hope you've enjoyed
that too anyway and obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the season the
game and also if there's anything we
missed I'm proud of you Paul Hall I did
it Paul way to go Paul Paul call Paul
but Paul better call Paul I understood
that reference but Paul we still got to
call you out in the two big ones you
miss you missed yeah uh what was it the
drinking reference with Ellie uh about
uh Riley said it still tastes like [__]
or whatever she said and then the other
one Laura Bailey is the nurse like Paul
oh that's two you missed man get your
[__] together Paul come on get your [__]
together but yeah no this season was a
fun ride um again I'm I'm still
surprised Paul hated it with the 8 out
of 10 rating so uh but uh I know you
love you you enjoy it I'm like a nine
out of 10.
yeah it's like a 9.5 yeah yeah I think a
lot of the things you're talking about
with um just like again feeling the
terror and the horror of the infected
and other little things might have just
scooched it up just a little bit but
like I'm right around that nine nine-ish
9.5 range as well as you so I as you
could tell we hated it as well so sorry
about all the whining I gave you guys
this season sorry about being so
fringe-worthy All Season uh sorry I know
you've been requesting Greg to get rid
of me some of you on here so uh
yeah sorry really way too many comments
I do Greg has warned me to stay away
from it I've I've been people have been
like John get rid of Greg and I'm like
you can't actually do that
um what's the owner of the channel yeah
yeah so no I mean I I like look I like
interacting with people though I've uh
when I do apparently when I do interact
with people which is Andrew Gordon it's
just my YouTube thing on there that's
not my actual channel it's just my name
I've been accused of not being the real
Andrew so if I do interact with you and
it's Andrew Gordon if you have gotten to
this point of the video which I'm sure
you have it thanks Paul but if you have
gotten to this point I am Andrew Gordon
so when I interact with you and you say
I'm not the real Andrew it is really me
so um but no look I I seriously I I
don't mind constructive criticism like I
don't mind that it's just when you get
personal it's that that's the time where
it's like uh what did I what did I do
you can't ask them not to get personal
you're just gonna make them get more
personal that's true that's true no but
seriously like B is constructive as you
want with me I I do not mind that in any
way if there's something you disagree
with with me like in regards to that
action sequence that uh that I was
thought was missing in episode eight if
you thought there's a reason why they
shouldn't have had it in there
absolutely I'm down for a debate like
but it's like you know he's a whiner and
he's a complainer I was like I rewatched
what I was saying I was like oh God
where are my wife you guys stop reading
I know I do Jesus well there is a reason
why I am in therapy now so I read too
many comments you're talking so much you
got too much you guys too much you gotta
get off your chest to defend yourself
stop it nah they're going to attack you
no matter what the way it goes that's
the way it goes trust me I've been down
the Wormhole of arguing unnecessarily
and being like unsubscribed then leave
I'm not so bad at me yeah but seriously
no I'm an expert I should do a patreon
the day shout out it's so late but
before we do seriously seriously thank
you to all you who have been with us no
not even McDonald's
like the people who like you don't even
think I wasn't thinking the people like
me I just said thank you for all the
people who've been with us through all
these don't even thank them okay
horrible and they're everyone who
watches us you're all terrible people
that's the goal you alienate everyone is
your enemy that's how you survive
only the haters not the lovers yeah
there you go
do I pick the patreon of the day yeah I
do it who do you got I got it I I mean
we've got to keep it last of us so who
do you think I'm going with if I'm
keeping it last of us I gotta go with
Maria Maria Hammond Maria that's that's
uh Tommy's wife why don't you grab that
for me go go ahead Andrew leave the
headphones the red thing yeah so go find
out what that red thing is
Maria Hammond gave me this red thing
I have a photo that I need to take on a
social media it stays on my edit each
year Marie I have an editing chair and
it stays on me
it is it's the cloak of levitation it's
always on my editing share and sometimes
I legit use it if like when we had the
rainstorms and I was like oh I need a
jacket I would just put this on I
weirdly have used this for not that's
cosplay but it's like an actual blanket
when I need it I want to see it levitate
towards you without me having to bring
it like that would be something Maria
only has so much money she can't afford
to buy that one it's the real real she
can't go to commartaj and get this whole
thing and there's also a big box present
over there that I got to unbox because
we got it from Arena as well she spoils
us
everything for that but I can't get this
button on tonight for some reason but
anyways right now we're running short on
okay actually you know what why don't
you do it I'm probably gonna fail but uh
look at me look me in the eyes when you
do it Andrew
you're not looking me in the eyes oh my
God no look back at the button yeah you
did it I did it thank you Maria for your
inspiration thank you Maria for the
inspiration and for my cloak of
levitation it's beautiful and now I am
Dracula
sounded like Jason Siegel in forgetting
Doctor Strange
that's a good thing but Maria uh you are
a gem and you provide us with gems and
you know the conversations that we have
were you were extremely open and
transparent and willing to be vulnerable
it's hard to find a good woman like you
out there because 99 of women are the
problem with our world
[Laughter]
I'm just joking you're you're such a
sweetheart and I love you to death I'm
going to send you a message on Twitter
very very soon Maria very soon I want to
see a doctor strange film Benedict
Cumberbatch doing the Dracula
impersonation now I'm not I'm never
gonna unsee that now thanks Greg
yeah okay
[Music]